je veux cela la parole est maintenant à
madame laurence vichnievsky pour le
groupe modem monsieur le président
madame la garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues je crois que mon
ancienne vie très proche va influencer
la nature de mon propos je le sais rien
n'est tout noir d'un côté à ma gauche ou
tout blanc de l'autre à ma droite la
symbolique de la fonction que j'exerçais
c'est l équilibre la balance et je
souhaite et en rester taisante parce que
je souhaitais aussi poursuivre mon
apprentissage vous livrer une
explication de vote équilibré et
distanciée si les textes que nous venons
d'examiner à des rythmes très
contrastées concrétise une promesse du
président de la république soucieux de
répondre rapidement aux exigences
légitimes des français
s'agissant de la probité leurs
responsables politiques dont certains
une minorité ont dû ou doit rendre des
comptes à la justice pénale
je souhaite m'exprimer au nom du modem
rendre hommage à françois bayrou
inspirateur et premiers rédacteurs de
ces projets de loi au nom du
gouvernement je veux aussi remercier
madame la garde des sceaux pour avoir
porté et défendu ses textes devant notre
assemblée avec rigueur élégance et
patience ces projets de loi ont été
enrichis par les débats parlementaires
au sénat comme sein de notre hémicycle
au terme de ces échanges qui aurait sans
doute mérité d'être plus rigoureux mieux
tu rates eu
et plus cadrés sans pour autant qu'il
soit porté atteinte à l'expression
politique de chacun chacune d'entre nous
nous sommes parvenus à élaborer de bons
textes ils contiennent des dispositions
majeures qui répondent largement aux
objectifs que nous poursuivons plus de
transparence plus de contrôle et de
garde-fous pour l'exercice de leurs
fonctions par les responsables
politiques et ce de manière à regagner
la confiance de nos concitoyens pour ne
citer que les plus emblématiques la
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
la justification il contrôle de nos
frais demandait l'interdiction des
emplois familiaux la nécessaire probité
des élus avec une liste conséquente
d'infraction entraînant l'inégibilité la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts la
création d'une banque de la démocratie
mes chers collègues ces textes nous
protège il nous protège de nos dérives
possibles de celles de nos
collaborateurs et de celle des membres
du gouvernement
bien sûr ils ne sont pas parfaits ils ne
sont pas exhaustifs non plus et oui nous
avons quelques regrets le verrou bercy
dont l'aménagement et non la suppression
avait recueilli le soutien de la grande
majorité des groupes politiques du sénat
et de l'assemblée
la non-inclusion peu compréhensible des
détournements de fonds privés
escroquerie abus de confiance abus de
biens sociaux dans la liste des
infractions entraînant l'inéligibilité
enfin le rejet d'une meilleure
définition des partis politiques de
manière à éviter un financement public
abusif mais nous avons aussi pris acte
de la création d'une mission
d'information sur le verrou fiscale et
je remercie madame la présidente et
rapporteur de la commission des lois
pour cette initiative sur laquelle nous
fondons beaucoup d'espoir
nous savons que la confiance ne se
décrète pas nous le savons tous et
qu'elle nécessite un changement culturel
qu'il nous faudra du temps pour la
rétablir mais nous n'avons pas le choix
mes chers collègues nous devons relever
ce défi et si nous prenons un peu de
recul
ces textes vont dans la bonne direction
c'est une première étape il y en aura
d'autres notre groupe modem et
apparentés les votera avec conviction
merci